good morning my name is Colleen this is
a day in the life of a freelance
software engineer my day starts at about
6:30 when my kids wake me up I am here
with them having some breakfast do you
want to say hi do you want to say hi I
will check back in with you and my
workday starts so my workday starts at
8:00 a.m. when my babysitter arrives I
have three kids one in full-day school
one in half-day nursery school and one
that is still home
so juggling all of that can be a little
bit challenging
when I first started out I was not
making enough money to hire a babysitter
and so I was hustling to get work done
late into the night early in the morning
and during nap time having the freedom
to have her here has really made a
difference now that I have a good
clientele and I'm making money she has
been a tremendous help I am NOT one of
those people that can work with my kids
running around I like quiet I like
intense focus with what I do so that has
really added to my productivity I have
three kids in a three-bedroom house so
my office is in my master bedroom
I have a new MacBook Pro here that I
work and a 27-inch monitor it's kind of
hard to appreciate how big that is on
this video but it's amazing I love it I
thought about going to co-working space
so I could meet more people but I love
my monitor and I think I would miss it
too much one of the things about
freelancing is there's a lot more
overhead than you would think you think
hey I'm gonna bill 40 hours a week at
$100 an hour I'm gonna be rich but the
reality is you're not gonna bill 40
hours in a week unless you're working 60
at least that's been my experience so
far there's a lot of overhead especially
as you're ramping up I've been doing
this for about a year so although I have
a pretty good backlog right now I
probably keep about a three-month
backlog of work so I'm always looking
for new clients and I'm always managing
those clients that's the other thing
because I have so many clients managing
them actually takes a little bit of my
time
this morning I'm gonna start with
checking my email and I have a new
client who has sent me a contract so I
have to read the contract and sign the
contract and that client has also sent
me their github repo so I have to look
at the code and see what kind of issues
I need to fix I've noticed or one of the
things about being a freelancer is you
switch code bases quite often and
there's always a ramp up time when
you're learning a new code base trying
to identify the issues that you have
been hired to solve one of the really
cool things about this is I see a lot of
different styles I see a lot of
different gems used for different things
but one of the kind of frustrating
things is it can slow you down a little
bit because you do need that ramp up
period for a new code base so I'll start
my day looking at that contract checking
my email getting that signed then I'm
going to have to go into my time
tracking tool I use harvest there's a
lot of good ones out there but I've been
using harvest I've been happy with it it
provides time tracking and invoicing and
I will have to add this new client and I
will have to start billing hours the
thing you have to be very very specific
on when you are a freelancer is your
hours so you have to be very diligent in
billing the correct hours to the correct
client and so I think having a time
tracking tool works way better than
trying to use Excel at a time or
something like that
so I signed the contract I told you I
was gonna look at and I just cloned a
new repo I'm gonna be working on while
that was cloning I hopped on to slack to
check in with my slack teams one of the
organization's I work for is a contract
basis so I get a little bit of work from
them every week and we use slack to
communicate I try not to keep slack on
all day because it can be distracting
so I clone the repo and I am having
problems I can't even open the code yet
that's always really frustrating a lot
of times you'll see that sometimes they
all use different versions of Ruby and
rails I use our BEM Arbonne to manage my
versions so it's actually not a problem
but I just it does you know it is a
little thing you got to go you got to
figure out what they're using why is it
my gem file working that kind of stuff
so that's what I'm doing right now like
I said I check it on slack and
everything is good there are no updates
for me with one company I contract with
I get paid when my pull request is
merged so I like to hop onto github to
see if there were any comments on my
pull request and see what status that is
in and then I sometimes use the Pomodoro
Technique to focus depending on what I'm
doing which is 25 minutes of intense
focus five minute break so I think I'm
not gonna start that until I can get the
repo working properly and once I get
that and I'm really diving in with the
code I'll start my Pomodoro mode
Pomodoro mo Pomodoro mo what do you say
has Pomodoro Pomodoro timer it's about
12 o'clock I spent the morning getting
set up with the new code base that I'm
gonna be start I'm going to start
working on this week and also taking on
some other issues for one of my contract
clients if you're wondering why I'm
laying on the floor it's because I use
the Pomodoro Technique which is 25
minutes on five minutes off so for those
25 minutes I turn off my email I turn
off my slack and I try to focus for my
five minutes off I do some yoga and I do
10 push-ups and then if I have time left
over I do some laundry so I'm gonna get
back to work and I will check in with
you around lunchtime
good afternoon it's about one o'clock so
it's lunchtime one of the things about
having my toddler in my house while I'm
trying to work is I have to stay out of
sight
while she is down here so I sneak down
here during nap time and get my lunch I
don't know about you but one of the
problems I always had working from home
is I wouldn't make lunch and then I'd
get hungry and then I was too lazy to
make lunch so I would just eat chips and
salsa but I have started making these
mason jar salads does not look delicious
and I eat them because they are super
convenient so I just dump this in a bowl
and I can eat it all right I don't
really break for lunch because time is
money and as long as I'm paying my
babysitter I want to be working so I'll
probably I'll grab my beautiful salad
dump it in a bowl and I will take it
back to my little cave slash office it's
about three o'clock and my babysitter
just left and I got my little one here
up from her nap next we are going to
pick up my eldest son from school and
then hopefully we'll have some fun
outside and get to enjoy the day a
little bit and probably check back in
later one of the biggest benefits of
being a freelancer is having flexibility
over my own schedule so as I mentioned I
worked at 8:00 to 3:00 today it's about
4:30 and I brought my kids to the
beautiful Norfolk Botanical Gardens and
they are playing on the world's biggest
hi my name is Declan I'm digging for
treasure that has candy and siding
I'm back at my desk
it's 7:30 at night I just put the kids
to bed and there's a lot of work I have
to get done I'm traveling the second
half of this week for a conference which
is awesome but being a freelancer I
built our lease so if I'm not working
I'm not getting paid that means I have
to put in some hours in the evenings to
make
at the time I'm gonna lose also it's not
as consistent as I used to think I
thought being a freelancer meant I could
just take time off whenever I wanted but
the reality is you have a lot of clients
that you work with continuously and it's
important to meet their deadlines and
make sure you don't let them down in
order to keep their business so I will
probably work here till I don't know
nine thirty or so and then I'll go to
bed thanks for watching bye